c'est toute la journée vous avez aimé la
radio le matin vous avez trois chances
sur quatre de tomber sur un mec qui vous
explique la vie vous allez mets la télé
le soir vous avez 300 sur quatre d'avoir
un mec qui vous raconte comment ça
marche la vie vous allez à votre boulot
vous allez avoir au bout de la table
trois chances sur quatre d'avoir un mec
qui est président la Réunion alors c'est
comme ça toute la journée chaque jour de
la semaine donc je pense que c'est pas
trop demander qu'on est quelquefois on
puisse être entre nous Alice au fin elle
a pas tort dans ce qu'elle dit là dans
tous les vocabres qu'on emploie
aujourd'hui je suis très
intersectionnelle ça veut dire croiser
plusieurs variables ensemble nous les
féministes on a toujours dit il y a il y
a le genre il y a le social je me
revendique comme
universalisme avec la présence des deux
sexes égaux et libre voilà
[Musique]